Hello Freak bitches. Oh, you know,
I mean it is interesting to hear people's
take on the climate issue because
there's hard left and hard, right.
Hard, right. Is it's a cycle.
It's always happened this way and you're,
you're impeding business.
Hard left is we're all going to die
and then Miami's going to drown.
I mean an Al Gore dirty predicted in
that movie an inconvenient truth that we
were going to be covered
in water in 2014 right.
Wasn't it 2014 they were predicting that
the ocean levels are gonna rise to the
point where we're going to have to start
evacuating some of the coastal cities.
That's right. He missed that one
just by a little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
But eight came out with another movie.
12 people.
So inconvenient truth
and um, nobody, nobody,
I just watched it I don't think,
but it's you see bill Nye when he
was on Tucker Carlson show. No,
it was very interesting.
It's very interesting cause I'm bill
Nye who's not really a scientist.
What is he? Is he at? He's
an end just in an engineer's
engineer. That's, yeah. Just,
you know,
based to have to be smart.
But he calls himself
Bill Nye the science guy.
He's bothered by the way
as an Undergrad degree.
So I don't even nice to have a phd.
I got one day and they were uh,
they were talking about climate
change and Tucker Carlson said,
I'm willing to absolutely believe that
people have an impact on climate change.
He goes,
but can you tell me how much?
And then bill and I kind of got
flustered and you know, he, he,
he got like a little confrontational,
defensive.
It's really kind of interesting because
Tucker kept pestering him like we're
talking about science.
So I would like you to tell me how
much of an impact have people had.
What are the numbers? Is it a narrow
range? Cause you give me a narrow range.
It's just what he does is he publicizes
science for his own personal benefit.
Is that terrible show on Netflix?
Bill Nye saves the World Bitchy,
not saving shit. Okay. You can't call,
you show Bill Nye saves the fucking world.
You're not saving the world with
this crazy goddamn song about gender.
And he has all my God.
Yeah. You see that that was,
that was stunning and I ended
up who the fuck greenlit dad?
Like I love Netflix, but hey, the
little quality controls on a bad thing,
like just have somebody on set to go
hope what we'll say in the fuck is this
like this, like a sensor like in the
old, but that movie good morning Vietnam.
Yeah. Somebody that sits there and reads
through his material before he does it.
Now I saw that now that you know clearly
they don't have anybody who has to
approve his content and shows
you where his mind's at,
that he's willing to say yes to that.
That's someone who wants to act.
We ask with no uncertain
terms to the left. Yeah,
like he just wants to every meanwhile
he had a film out of a movie or a
television show out years ago while
he was describing gender and it was
basically saying there's two genders.
Right, and it's about x and y chromosome.
I mean, which is what everybody's been
told in science and biology class.
Then he has this show just a few years
later where now the tide has turned
politically where this is such a weird
subject about gender and sexual identity
and gender identity. And so he's
got these songs about, you know,
like what that lady singing
that song like, Hey,
this is fucking terrible.
Like what you all you're doing.
It's just like the same thing as
president Trump staring at the sun.
All you're doing is setting
yourself up for rootless criticism.
That's going to diminish any potential
legitimate point that you actually have.
But I will say this, I don't think he
really got pilloried for it, right?
I mean nobody really. Um, there was
some, there was some line, yeah.
I think some people make fun of them,
but I think bill knife for the most part,
he knows it. That's, that's a very
comfortable place for him to do.
Or for a lot of people, if they say, look,
I just want to get the adulation of
the left of the far left and then fine.
I mean that's what you wanna do,
do it.
But you see people that kind
of shift their position.
And are happy to be there because they
know they're going to be coddled. And I,
so I, I get why he does it
because it's a base of, of a,
it's an audience that he knows is going
to stick with them as long as he says
the right things. And apparently he
doesn't really give a shit about science.
So he's happy to say anything. Well, I
think he does give a shit about science.
He gives a shit and more about people
liking him and fitting in with this crowd
of people. There's a weird thing
that's going on in science and it's,
there's nothing like,
science is fantastic. It's,
it's critical for our civilization.
I'm not a science criticizer but there's
a weird thing about people that are a
part of science where their own egos and
their own need for positive affirmation
sort of supersede any critical thinking.
So there's certain subjects
that cannot be discussed.
There's certain things that like,
they're, they're almost like, yeah,
it's almost like science,
religion, you know.
So there's certain subjects that are,
aren't even open to scrutiny.
Well, I think that's right.
And I think part of it is, is,
is also we have gotten to a point where
you can't, and I don't know how you,
you walk it back, but you, you,
you can't have conflicting ideas in the
same statement or the same sentence and
an idea if things conflict all the time.
Right.
And then you can have a truths that,
that collide with each other and don't,
I don't necessarily make sense, so,
but it seems as if now everything has to
be an absolute and whether it's climate
change, so you can't
say, you know, if you,
if you just have this middle of the road,
you know,
discussion where you're saying,
well look, of course, you know,
humans I'm sure have some impact. I
don't know what that is. And then,
and you know,
this is a problem,
then we do have to do our part and we
do have to work to try to be the best we
can be. But that's not good enough.
You've got to, you've got to be a,
you know, sort of totalitarian about the
whole issue. And it's not just that it's,
it's any argument. It just seems as
if, and it's not just the millennials,
I'm not wanting to, to, you
know, beat on, you know,
the young kids are the generation of
whatever we want to call nowadays.
Cause I know a lot of good kids that
are out there that are working hard or
they're in the military. It's a
fantastic, you know, group of folks.
So I think we're just fine in that regard.
But there does seem to be something
about each successive generation.
And we've gotten now to a point where
people have a hard time processing this
dissenting opinion idea.
And that starts to shut down debate
and it starts to shut down the,
the idea that you can have a discussion
about science where you have, you know,
these conflicting ideas and how do you,
how do you resolve them?
That used to be the whole concept about
sciences to test theories and correct
with what works. And anyway, right.
I think it's because we're attaching egos
and personalities and virtue signaling
to the actual hard data itself.
But here's,
here's the thing that we should
all be concerned with pollution.
We should all be concerned
with human waste.
We should all be concerned with the
damage that we're doing to our water,
the damage that we're doing
to the environment, the, the,
there's a host of different things that
human beings are involved in that are
creating irreparable
harm to the environment.
We should absolutely
be concerned with that.
But what's weird is that you
hardly ever hear about that.
You hardly ever hear about doing something
to curb the plastic in the ocean,
doing something to eliminate that.
Some of the sewage waste that
goes into the ocean doing the, oh,
there's a ton of different things
that we're doing that are huge issues,
but instead you hear about climate change
and it becomes this ideological left
versus right battle, which is,
it's just very weird to me.
And I understand that climate change
is a real issue and if the ocean water
continues to rise,
coastal cities really are fucked.
And if the temperature does rise,
we really might have to migrate to
more and you know, better climates.
But there's a lot of other shit going on,
but it seems to get ignored
during this process.
I mean, I, you know, I'm old
enough to remember when, uh,
plastics that was an issue,
right? Plastic bags or, or, um, you know,
keeping the oceans clean or, you
know, don't be a little about, I mean,
it was more of a, it was things
that you could accomplish, right?
It was things that you could do
with the community. Could do.
So you would have these community drive
to pick up trash or to not use plastic
bags or to whatever it is.
And it was stuff that you could do
and you could see some results and it,
and you felt good about it.
And you know, who knows?
Maybe we've gone past that now and so now,
uh,
that's not good enough because now
we've got to save the planet. Well,
you save the planet these little
steps at a time, right? If every,
every community says,
well, you know, sorry,
I can't do anything about the polar bears,
so fuck it.
I'm just going to worry about myself.
But if you,
if you bring it back down to those
little things like you would, you know,
maybe implying, then I think
we're better off. Yeah. Right.
And eventually you,
you do make a difference.
But if all you do is talk about
climate change and save the planet,
people just get overwhelmed.
It's like a lot of other things
in life and you just, fuck it.
I'm just going to focus on other shit.
Let's just so strange to climate change
to become this weird ideological debate
between the left and the right.
Yeah.